So, the next thing I'm showing
on the slide are two of
the refinements that are being used
in this assembly specification.
Refinements are little
program generators.
They take existing programs of
some type that implements some
predetermined interfaces.
And, they compose those programs to
generate a new program, or new variant,
that implements some other interface.
So, for example, we have here
a refinement called Incor for
incremental forecaster.
And, Incor is parametrized by two
different kinds of arguments,
one is some component that
implements forecast interface.
The other is some component that
implements the Multipliers interface.
And, when I apply this refinement to
components of those suitable types, then
I'll actually generate a new component
that implements the forecast interface.
Likewise, for the FCST refinement,
it's parameterized by two components
that implement the forecast interface,
and it generates a new component
that implements forecast interface.
>> So,
I'd like to relate this term as well.
Earlier In this class, we've talked
about using refinement to go from
an abstract description of something
to a more concrete description.
It sounds like your refinements here are
doing that with some kind of generator.
>> Exactly, yeah so, but it's meant to
appeal to that same sensibility, right?
You can think of an interface as
representing an abstract program that
fills in some details.
In particular, in our case, the
signatures of the different tables that
are going to maintain calculations
that we want to make, like forecasts.
But,hey may be implemented in many,
many, many different ways.
And so, each refinement Is a generator
that will generate a different way
of implementing that interface.
It really is meant to
appeal the same idea.